également dit qu'aucun président des
états unis ne peut être honnête envers
le peuple américain s'il ne parle pas
aux efforts pour défendre nos valeurs
démocratiques se porter garant pour les
valeurs universelles de la liberté dont
sont dotés les hommes et les femmes
selon nous cela relève de l'adn de notre
pays donc les droits humains figurant
toujours sur la table je lui ai dit il
ne s'agit pas simplement de s'en prendre
à la russie lorsqu'il viole les droits
de l'homme non cela relève de notre état
le profond comment est-ce que moi
président des états unis
pourrais-je m'abstenir de parler contre
les violations des droits de l'homme je
le lui ai dit
contrairement à d'autres pays comme la
russie nous sommes uniquement le produit
d'une idée je les dis encore et toujours
et je continue à te le dire nous sommes
le produit d'une idée nos droits ne
seront pas dérivé du gouvernement nous
avons ses droits parce que nous sommes
nés tout simplement et nous laisser dont
au gouvernement et donc je lui ai dit
que c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
allons susciter faire parler de nos
préoccupations dans des affaires telles
que celle de monsieur navalni j'ai dit
clairement à monsieur poutine que nous
allons continuer par des questions des
droits de l'homme car cela relève de
notre identité c'est qu'ils nous sommes
pour nous ce sont des vérités évidentes
à savoir tous les hommes et les femmes
nous n'avons pas toujours été à la
hauteur de ses des idéaux mais nous
avons maintenu ses engagements
de plus en plus de populations
j'ai parlé de la situation des citoyens
américains qui s'obtient pas loin d'être
hybrides chez également parlé de
questions de radio free europe radio
europe qui puisse fonctionner et
l'importance d'une presse libre de la
liberté d'expression je dis clairement
que nous ne tolérons pas les attaques
contre le souverain et démocratique où
les tentatives de lutter contre les
élections démocratiques
nous allons réagir essentiellement jeudi
auprès du repos think it de levon de
doter de règles de la situation de base
c'est que nous
se respecte et je lui ai également dit
qu'il ya des domaines de coopération
d'intérêt mutuel pour nos populations
le peuple américain est pour le peuple
russe mais également sur le bien du
monde entier pour la sécurité du monde
entier
l'un de ces domaines c'est la stabilité
stratégique
vous me demandez souvent de quoi je
parlais avec poutine avant de venir je
lui dis que je n'ai pas négocié avec la
leaf du jeu lui dit ce que j'avais
l'intention de faire depuis le début à
savoir parler de ces questions de la
stabilité stratégique et pour essayer de
se doter d'un mécanisme pour gérer ces
dossiers nous avons parlé en détail des
étapes que devront prendre en matière de
contrôle des armements
les étapes nécessaires pour réduire les
risques de conflit inédit imprévisible
et aujourd'hui nous allons lancer un
dialogue stratégique de stabilité c'est
un langage diplomatique pour dire que
nos experts militaires ne diplomatique
se rencontrant pour créer un mécanisme
qui pourra déboucher sur le contrôle des
nouveaux armements sophistiqués
dangereux qui sont déjà en train de
naître qui réduisent les délais de
réponse qui rit augmente les risques de
guerre accidentelle nous avons parlé de
manière détaillée de ces systèmes
d'armement nous avons également passé
beaucoup de temps à parler de la
cybersécurité j'ai parlé de cette idée
que certains a fracturé stratégique ne
doivent jamais être attaqué point à la
ligne
une des manières cyberéthique ou autre
je lui donnais une liste si je m'abuse
je n'ai pas demain en moi mais il ya 16
entités spécifiques 16 entités définit
comme relevant de l'infrastructure
fondamentale des états unis les systèmes
de lowe's ce principe est fondamentale
et cela doit être étayé par la pratique
lépi responsables à prendre des mesures
contre les criminels qui prennent des
mesures de rang sans sur leur propre
territoire
c'est pourquoi nous sommes convenus
de missionner des experts les deux pays
pour s'attaquer à des compressions de ce
qui est inacceptable et parler de cas
spécifiques qui origine dans l'un ou
l'autre de nos pays il y à une longue
liste de dossiers sur lesquels nous
avons discuté il ya un besoin urgent de
rouvrir les couloirs en militaires année
en séries pour que l'on puisse apporter
de la nourriture les éléments
fondamentaux pour les gens qui sont
affamés comment on reconstruire et
comment cela relève des états des
intérêts des états unis et de la russie
pour y est ce que l'iran ne se dote pas
d'armes nucléaires
nous avons décidé de travailler ensemble
cela relève des intérêts de aussi comme
des nôtres comment pouvons-nous veiller
à ce que l'article domaine une zone de
coopération plutôt qu'une zone de
conflit j'écoutais des séquences la
conférence de presse du président
poutine et il a parlé du fait que nous
devons avoir un modus operandi pour nous
permettre de faire en sorte que
l'article soit effectivement une zone
libre et comment on nous tous ensemble
contribuer à cette lutte contre c'est
très dur en sus terrorisme en
afghanistan
cela enlève encore une fois des intérêts
de la russie d' d'éviter un retour du
terrorisme en afghanistan
il ya également dix dossiers plus
difficile
j'ai dit que les états unis maintenaient
leur engagement indéfectible vis-à-vis
de l'intégrité territoriale de l'ukraine
nous avons décidé de suivre la voie
diplomatique par rapport à la porte de
minsk
j'ai parlé de mes préoccupations
revendre à l'âme et de russie il n'était
pas en désaccord par rapport à ce qui
s'était passé il avait tout simplement
pas lu différents
je sais que vous avez beaucoup de
questions je vais conclure avec ce
propos il était important de se
rencontrer en personne pour qu'il n'y
ait aucune erreur aucune fausse
représentation en ce qui concerne ce que
je souhaitais communiqué
j'ai fait ce que je voulais faire
premièrement j'ai identifié des domaines
de travail pratique pour le deux pays
pour favoriser nos intérêts mutuels pour
nous mêmes et pour le monde
deuxièmement communiquer de manière
directe directement que les états unis
réagiront à des actions qui sont contre
nos intérêts vitaux aussi deux alliés et
troisièmement énoncer clairement quelles
sont nos priorités quels sont nos
valeurs pour qu'il entende directement
de ma bouche et je dois vous dire que le
la tonalité de ses rencontres de plus de
quatre heures
l'ambiance était bonne positive il n'y
avait pas d'action forte ou de prise de
parole il y avait des moments où nous
étions d'accord il a disputé son point
de vue expliqué les moyens mais cela a
été fait sans aucune hyperbole on voit
beaucoup trop de ces choses actuellement
au cours de la semaine écoulée
je crois j'espère que les états unis ont
démontré au monde que nous sommes de
retour
nous sommes aux côtés de nos alliés nous
avons rallié des démocraties prendre des
engagements concertée vous attaquer aux
plus grands défis du monde actuel est
présentement nous avons établi des bases
claires pour nous permettre de
travailler avec la russie et de gérer la
relation entre nos deux pays
il y a encore beaucoup de travail devant
nous non je ne dis pas que tout avec un
copie mais nous avons fait beaucoup de
choses pendant ce voyage
et avant de répondre à vos questions je
dirais une toute dernière chose écoutons
écouter il s'agit de l'étape suivante
géant encore une fois j'ai écouté une
grande partie de la conférence de presse
du président poutine
et comme il l'a dit lui-même il s'agit
d'une des décisions pratiques dit que
nous devons prendre ou ne pas prendre et
d'ici un an aux six mois nous verrons
effectivement si nous pourrons avoir ce
dialogue stratégique
nous nous rendrons compte si nous
pourrons parler de ces choses de la
libération des personnes qui sont en
prison en russie nous l'apprendrons si
nous aurons un accord de sécurité qui
commence à rétablir un semblant d'ordre
parce que les pays qui sont les plus
susceptibles d'être lésées ce sont les
grands pays
par exemple lorsque je parle de loups
les ducs qui a été pris par an 100 pour
5 millions de dollars aux états unis
je répare les comment le le centre y est
vous si on demandait aux rançons vous
oléoduc sa contraire cela relève pas que
nos intérêts propres cela relève de nos
intérêts mutuels
je répondrai à vos questions comme
d'habitude on m'a communiqué une liste
de personnes que je doit interpeller
johnattan de la société de presse
merci monsieur le président les
renseignements américains disent que la
russie a essayé de s'ingérer dans les
deux sélections américaines que les
russes sont derrière les attaques de
solo hince le président poutine vient de
dire qu'il n'acceptait aucune
responsabilité pour ces choses votre
père et ses heures il n'a pas demandé à
ce que poutine arrête ces perturbations
donc avez vous réalisé sur le plan
concret aujourd'hui pour éviter que cela
ne se reproduise à l'avenir bien j'ai
empêcher que cela se reproduise g qu'il
sait que je ferai le prendrait des
mesures comme c'était la toute dernière
fois en l'occurrence qui s'est passé
nous ont clairement dit que nous ne
permettrons pas battu rions pas que
celui-ci se poursuivent et par
conséquent il y a eu des rappels les
ambassadeurs nous avons fermé des
installations aux états unis il sait
qu'il ya des conséquences est bien l'une
des conséquences et je sais je ne sais
pas si je sais ce jeu
soupçonne que vous pensez que cela ne
compte pas cela compte pour lui pour les
dirigeants des grands pays
ce qui compte c'est sa crédibilité à
l'échelle mondiale
sa crédibilité à l'échelle mondiale
s'amenuisent
comment les a dit mr est il perçu par le
reste du monde
si nous nous nous ingérions directement
dans les élections d'autres pays et si
tout le monde le savait qu'est ce que ce
serait si nous pratiquions ses activités
qu'ils pratiquent lui-même
cela réduit le prestige d'un pays qui
essaye de maintenir son rang en tant que
grande puissance mondiale
donc cela dit ce n'est pas ce que je
fais qui compte seulement ce sont les
mesures prises par d'autres pays la
russie en l'occurrence qui sont
contraires aux normes internationales et
c'est le prix à payer
ils ne sont pas en mesure de dicter ce
qui se passe dans le reste du monde il y
à d'autres pays importants notamment des
états unis
parmi eux monsieur le président
s'agissant de conscience au pub n'est de
dire que vous lui avez beaucoup parlé de
droits de l'homme que se passerait-il si
le dirigeant de l'opposition alexis
navalni mouret je lui dis clairement que
je crois que les conséquences de cela
serait dévastatrice pour la russie je
reviens à mon point initial que se
passerait-il si il dit il ne s'agit pas
de nuire navalni bondi toutes ces choses
pour rationaliser de traitement de naval
nive et ensuite il meurt en prison
je lui dis que cela compte énormément
quand un pays en fait bon on m'a demandé
pourquoi cela était importante que l'on
ait des problèmes avec le présent la
syrie parce que il viole les normes
internationales avec le traité et des
armes sur les armes chimiques il n'est
pas fiable
c'est une question de confiance c'est
une question de sa capacité d'influer
les autres pays de manière positive
écoutez voudriez vous échanger notre
économie pour l'économie russe est en
fait nous avons parlé de commerce
je n'ai pas de problème de commercer
avec la russie tant qu'ils respectent
les normes internationales il relève de
nos intérêts que le peuple russe prenne
son essor s'épanouit soit plus
économique mais s'ils n'agissent pas en
fonction des normes internationales et
bien que se passe-t-il
cela ne se passera pas non seulement
avec les états unis mais avec d'autres
pays et il pelouse
il en a parlé il y à ce besoin de tendre
la main à d'autres pays qui investiront
aussi et bien ces pays n'investit rompt
pas tant qu'on ne peut pas les
convaincre que il ya ces violations par
exemple l'homme d'affaires américain qui
est en résidence surveillée et assigné à
résidence
si vous voulez que les investisseurs
américains viennent chez vous libérez le
changer la dynamique parce que les
hommes d'affaires américains sont pas
prêts à aller sur place à moscou je sais
on dit que la politique étrangère enlève
de ses compétences extraordinaires qu'il
y ait un code secret en fait la
politique étrangère c'est une extension
logique et des relations personnelles
c'est le fonctionnement de la nature
humaine il faut comprendre lorsque vous
dirige un pays qui ne respectent pas les
normes nationales et pourtant vous avez
besoin de ces normes internationales qui
doivent être prises en charge pour que
vous puissiez en profiter vous même
et bien cela vous est nuisible ce n'est
pas une bonne réponse mode debbie dunn a
dit non il en il va envahir la rue sinon
ce n'est pas vrai c'est une blague mais
mon point fondamental est le suivant les
choses sont plus compliquées que cela
david singer
je croyais avoir vu david merci monsieur
le président en amont de cette
discussion on a beaucoup parlé du fait
que les deux pays allaient entamer une
nouvelle guerre froide et je voudrais
savoir s'il y a à la suite de ces
discussions aient eu pas d'enjeu vo
t'aimons ma veste
il fait chaud y at il des raisons de
penser que monsieur poutine a décidé de
s'écarter de son rôle fondamental dans
deux distributeurs de perturbateurs
surtout un descripteur des états unis et
de l'otan et pour rebondir sur cette
liste comme le voulait ni
d'infrastructures critiques aux états
unis
avez vous énoncez très clairement quels
seraient les pénalités s'il y avait des
ingérences sur surface dure critique
est-ce que c'est resté vague at il
répondu d'une manière d'une autre bien
je vais répondre tout d'abord à votre
deuxième question je lui dis que nous
avons des capacités cybernétique
importante il le sait il ne sait pas
exactement de quoi il s'agit mais il le
sait et en fait ils ont violé ces normes
fondamentales et s'ils le font nous
allons réagir sur le plan cybernétique
il le sait de manière cybernétique un
deuxièmement je crois que ce qu'il veut
sans doute éviter à présent c'est une
guerre froide
je ne vais pas le citer ce ne serait pas
appropriée mais je vais vous poser une
question rhétorique il a une frontière
de milliers de kilomètres avec la chine
la chine avance rapidement elle veut
être la première économie du monde
elle veut être la force militaire la
plus puissante du monde et vous êtes
dans une situation où votre économie est
en difficulté vous devez avancer de
manière agressive en tout cas pour ce
qui concerne la croissance
et puis je ne pense pas qu'ils
recherchent une guerre froide avec les
états unis
je ne pense pas comme je lui dis je
dit votre génération est la mienne nous
avons dix années de distance nous sommes
pas un combat est un combat comme odysée
aux années 60 c'est pas le grand amour
mais cela relève pas de nos intérêts dus
votre lumière pour nous trouver dans une
situation nous serions dans une nouvelle
guerre froide
je crois fondamentalement qui le pense
aussi qu il le comprend mais cela ne
veut pas dire qu'il est prêt à renoncer
à ses armes non il est toujours
préoccupée d'être encerclés il est
toujours préoccupé par l'idée que nous
cherchons à le rabaisser un certain
niveau il a toujours ses préoccupations
mais je ne pense pas que ce sont les
forces motrices de la relation qu'il
cherche avec les états unis
jennifer jean fadjri cops
merci monsieur le président
y at il une raison toute particulière
qui expliquerait pourquoi ce sommet n'a
duré que trois heures pour ça que ça va
durer 4 5 heures est une raison pour
laquelle le sommet était plus court le
président poutine a dit qu'il n'ya pas
qui veut pas de menaces ou de tactique
de la peur est tous d'accord qu'il n'y
avait pas de menaces ou de tactique de
la peur et avez vous parlé de
l'afghanistan et du retrait sur de nos
troupes
oui oui oui et oui je vais répondre à
votre première partie la raison pour
laquelle le sommet n'a pas duré plus
longtemps ce parce que la dernière fois
deux chefs d'état avaient passé plus de
deux heures en conversation directe
autour de la table en parlant de détails
minutieux
vous connaissez peut-être une époque où
cela s'est passé
pas moi donc il n'était pas nécessaire
lorsque le groupe élargit nous a rejoint
nos collègues des renseignements des
affaires étrangères à savoir donc le
secrétaire d'état était avec moi pour
toute la durée nos ambassadeurs tout le
monde nous aura joindre nous avions déjà
couvert tant de sujets
donc nous avons fait un sommaire lui et
moi des sujets dont nous avons parlé
messieurs lavrov et messieurs blinken en
parler des sujets abordés
nous avons parlé de sujets qui
nécessitent plus d'applications pour
éviter tous les malentendus
par conséquent en fait après ces deux
heures nous nous sommes consultés et
nous avons nous avons dit d'accord et
est maintenant et bien que va-t-il se
passer matin et bien nous allons pouvoir
prendre du recul et regarder de l'avant
d'ici trois à six mois et nous dire eh
bien les choses sur lesquelles nous nous
sommes entendus on est le marché sommes
nous plus proche d'eux pour parler de
stabilité stratégique est ce que nous
avançons donc ce sera le test je ne dis
pas que le président et moi même avons
convenu que nous pourrions tous et si
tout cela est que tous ceux ci
fonctionnera non ce n'est pas ce que je
dis je dis tout simplement qu'il ya des
perspectives réelles d'amélioration des
relations entre nos deux pays
sans renoncer à quoi que ce soit sur la
base de nos principes et de nos valeurs
non non il n'y avait pas de menaces et
en fait j'ai entendu qu'il avait cité ma
mère et d'autres personnes aujourd'hui
comme on le dit cela vous choquerait
venu dans ma part c'est un peu familier
et nous avons parlé de choses basiques
est fondamentale
vous savez comment je suis j'explique
les choses sur le plan personnel comment
je vois les choses qu'il n'y aurait pas
de menace ou tout simplement des
déclarations simples et bien nous ferons
ceci nous ferons cela
il lui fait part de mes positions je lui
ai expliqué ce que nous pourrions
accomplir ensemble et que se passa-t-il
co for you know s'il y avait des
violations de la souveraineté américaine
c'est lui qui nous a posé des questions
sur l'afghanistan il nous a dit qu'il
espérait que nous serions en mesure de
maintenir la paix la sécurité je lui
répondis que cela dépend en grande
partie de vous il a répondu qu'il était
prêt je cite à nous aider je n'entrerai
pas dans les détails il a dit qu'il
serait prêt à nous aider avec l'iran
mais je lui dis ce que nous souhaitions
faire en matière de stabilité et de
sécurité économiques la sécurité
physique halle pour le peuple syrien et
le peuple libyen a donc nous avons eu
ces discussions il ya michel
oui merci monsieur le président il vous
dit que vous n'avez pas fait de menaces
mais ce que vous avez lancer des
ultimatums en ce qui concerne le
logiciel de rancio le scud et s'agit
sort de ces groupes de travail sur la
gérance se ruent c'est sûr à subir
sécurité et bien ce sera très facile par
exemple s'agissant d'un cyber sécurité
nous allons voir s'il s'attaque aux
criminels ou de logiciels rossant sur le
territoire je ne pense pas qu'ils ont
planifié en l'occurrence vont ils agir
eh bien nous ne rendrons compte quels
sont les engagements que nous pouvons
prendre en matière d'action de mesures
suite à l'immolation de natation pas la
russie qu avons nous accepté de faire en
fait nous avons une véritable chance
d'avancer et je pense que l'une des
choses que nous avons constaté lors de
la réunion élargie c'est le fait que les
gens qui ont commencé à se dire ceci
pourrait être un véritable problème
ses rangs sang si vous êtes dans un état
américain en floride ou romaine
par exemple si elle est une région qui
est demandé pour un élément vital de
l'économie
et bien ce serait dévastateur eh bien
les gens doivent se rencontrent cela
relève des intérêts de tout à chacun
eh bien nous verrons ce qui se passe à
la suite des ces groupes de travail que
nous allons établir
monsieur le président lorsque le
président poutine a été interrogé sur
les droits de l'homme
il a dit que la raison pour laquelle ils
interpellent des dirigeants de
l'opposition il veut pas que des choses
telles que 6 janvier se passe dans ce
pays il ne veut pas qu'il y ait des
groupes tels que blacklight mater dans
son pays qui ont répondrai que répondez
vous à cela la réponse est celle que
j'ai déjà communiqué à savoir c'est une
comparaison ridicule bon que des
criminels entre au capital --via la
sécurité tuent des officiers c'est une
chose
alors que des gens qui manifestent qui
disent vous ne permettez pas de
m'exprimer librement vous ne prêtez pas
de faire abaisser de donc ce sont des
choses tout à fait différentes
steve hollander writers monsieur le
président c'est le président poutine a
dit qu'il était satisfait de la réponse
que vous habitez lorsque vous avez dit
qu'il était un tueur pouvez vous nous
dire ce que vous avez dit il est
satisfait alors pourquoi est-ce que
j'abordais encore une fois cette
question
lorsque vous lui parlez pensez vous
pouvoir avoir confiance en lui ce n'est
pas une question de confiance
c'est une question d'intérêts propres
est de la vérification de ses intérêts
propres
cela relève de cela donc virtuellement
comme toutes les personnes avec
lesquelles je réaliserai un accord au
président américain je ne dis pas j'ai
confiance en vous n'y a pas le problème
non on attend de voir ce qui s'y passe
donc il faut voir avec le résultat final
on n'est pas encore sûr igor radio free
europe radio liberty vous voulez vous
mettre alors vous pouvez me voir
vous savez qu'il y à des attaques contre
la société civile et quand la presse
livre et ces choses se poursuivent en
russie par exemple radio free europe
radio liberty la voix de l'amérique et
la chaîne de télé où je travaille ont
été déclarées agents étrangers
et il ya d'autres médias indépendants de
même
essentiellement nous sommes forcés à
partir après 30 ans après que l'opposant
ariel si nous invitait donc ma question
est la suivante après vous discussions
avec le président poutine d'après vous
dans quelle mesure le climat des médias
va t'il s'améliorer en russie je ne
répondrai pas de cette façon en termes
d'amélioration du climat des médias mais
je dois dire à quel niveau
est-ce que cela relève de ses intérêts
d'améliorer la réputation de la russie
quand c'est un pays qui est contre et
valeurs démocratiques de liberté de
parole ce n'est pas une décision que je
peux prendre moi-même je ne pense pas
qu'il cherche à changer la nature d'une
société fermée
ou modifier les accords s'ils ont de son
gouvernement qui estime qu'il a droit de
faire ce qu'il fait il s'agit d'une
approche très différente
je lui dis que j'ai lu pratiquement tous
les textes qu'il a écrits tous les
discours qu'il a prononcé j'ai lu
plusieurs limon biographie de lui comme
vous les avez lu vous même et je lui
signaler que la russie avait une
opportunité ce moment très court après
et gorbatchev les changements drastiques
il avait la possibilité de se doter d'un
gouvernement démocratique
malheureusement cela a échoué et il y à
une course entre intellectuels russes
quant à déterminer quelle forme de
gouvernement il choisirait et comment le
choisir et il est sur la base de ma
conviction monsieur poutine a décidé que
la russie a toujours été une grande
puissance internationale lorsque la
russie était totalement unie en tant
qu'etat réussi et pas sur la base d'une
idéologie qu'il s'agisse des tins des
commissaires de l'époque révolutionnaire
de la révolution russe et jusqu'à leur
situation actuelle je pense
il m'apparaît clairement je les dis et
lui le décidé que la russie se
maintiennent en tant que grande
puissance c'est par le biais de
l'unification du peuple russe
grâce à la force du gouvernement du
contrôle du gouvernement pas forcément
sur le plan biologique mais tout
simplement le gouvernement je crois que
c'est le choix qui a été fait et je ne
vais pas
deviner si les choses auraient pu se
passer fondamentalement différemment
mais je crois que il veut que la russie
se maintiennent comme une des grandes
puissances mondiales
durant la conversation d'aujourd'hui
s'agissant de la ligne rouge cousein
établi aujourd'hui est-ce qu'une impasse
militaire possible sans ce qu'il faut ça
les demandes de rançon et vous avez dit
une fois qu'il n'avait pas d'âme
le comprenez vous mieux c'est réunion
s'agissant de la rue n'en avons pas
parlé de réponse militaire
vous avez dit que les discussions en
tête à tête sont tirés par irremplaçable
et vous avez parlé de la russie et de la
chine
vous avez dit à maintes reprises que
vous passerez probable en plus de temps
avec le passé en chic avec tout autre
dirigeant du monde donc le moment
viendra t'il où vous l'appellerait et
lui demanderez d'ouvrir la chine aux
enquêteurs de l'om à ce qu'ils cherchent
à savoir quelles sont les origines du
virus
oui nous nous connaissons depuis
longtemps mais ne sommes pas amis de
long 4
c'est une question vous avez dit que
vous allez mettre la pression soit chine
vous avez adhéré aux communiqués du g7
indiquant que le g7 demandé à la chine
de s'ouvrir aux enquêteurs mais la chine
dit qu'elle ne veut pas faire l'objet d'
ingérence
il est bien l'impact c'est l'attitude
par rapport à la chine
la chine essaie de se projeter comme un
état responsable est un pays en plein
essor
ils font beaucoup d'efforts pour montrer
qu'ils aident le monde
avec la crise et les vaccins et bien il
y à certaines choses qu'il n'est pas
nécessaire d'expliquer au monde
on voit les résultats est ce que la
chine souhaite effectivement arrivé au
fond de la cause du
blême comme je vous l'aï dit et au g7 et
avec le temps ce que nous devrions faire
ce que je vais m'efforcer de faire c'est
de rallier le monde pour nous attaquer à
ce qu'ils constitueront les mécanismes
physiques disponibles pour détecter le
plus tôt possible la prochaine pandémie
est pour nous trouve dotée des moyens
pourrait réagir le plus précocement
possible et ça se passera
voilà donc pour cette conférence de
presse de joe biden sur les bords du lac
léman elle a commencé à 19h20 il est
19h52 donc 22 minutes de conférence de
presse était plus court que vladimir
poutine on part tout de suite du côté de
genève